three years ago this week shootings
plagued gun appreciation day I don't
know if you remember this gun
appreciation day thing uh it was really
stupid and the chairman of it was named
Larry Ward and we actually interviewed
him and we've had very few interviews on
our program Louis where the guest
abruptly ends the interview what we call
hang up Larry Ward's interview was one
of them I invite you to check out that
interview and the entire gun
appreciation thing uh gun appreciation
day thing was a disaster there were gun
shows in Indiana and in Ohio and North
Carolina with shootings accidental
shootings as people like to call them i
call them negligent shootings they just
don't learn it last week we talked about
the Gabby Giffords shooting and how the
United States by and large learned very
little in terms of turning it into
action from the Gabby Giffords shooting
the gun appreciation day shootings
showed us the absurdity of this ammo
sexual obsession with guns that we have
i I've said it before I'll say it again
I don't know that anything could happen
with guns in this country no matter how
disastrous that would make the more guns
in more places crowd say hey you know
what maybe we need to reconsider no it
really only happens on an individual
basis I think that let's say one of
those people is affected somehow by gun
violence despite having a gun on them
right despite having guns in the home
and they realize that it either made no
difference or made the situation worse
maybe on an interval individual basis
you'll have some people change their
minds and we sent about enjoy this thing
what will never happen to any of them
right the what it's interesting because
every once in a while we'll get a story
from someone who said hey I'm all about
second amendment concealed carry I was
at this shooting and I had a gun and
when the craziness started I realized
what am I going to do if I take the gun
out how am I going to improve this
situation if I take the gun out that's a
situation very few people will ever be
in but sometimes it happens and they
realize I'm not gonna be able to add to
the situation here by adding my gun to
the flurry of gunshots yeah the problem
is that every gun owner thinks they're
Rambo or or James Bond so not all be we
get emails from some who say
I would never even think of getting
involved I care whether the person
talking I mean if if you're someone who
likes to collect guns and go target
shooting I what we're talking about the
types of people were seeing in the
picture here yeah uh they they do all
think they're Rambo or James Bond and
they think they'll they'll be in a
situation where uh they'll just dominate
and they loan it and everything will be
fine because they had a gun and until
they're in that situation you won't
change their mind